go and rest but it's purified don't know
why I make my intern vlogs anyway we're
in you can't see anything
waiting Tokyo and that's pretty awesome
actually
this is our last day I haven't blogged
anything because I don't felt like it
but I feel like last day I should be
vlogging so we're going out we're gonna
do a bunch of stuff today and I thought
I'd bring you bros along
so yeah let's go I can't do that in
public and you're fine you're all wet
now Japanese breakfast
so now we finished I feel so fat we're
going to the temple thing we're going to
do we're going to a park so we have to
take the subway and I'll see you there
so we just took the subway I wrote know
where we are
we go - I got this part if it's the
right place I really don't know civil
see we're in the park it's pretty
exciting
there's people it's pretty though hmm
yeah we're going to we saw there was
like a sign for Ghibli Museum and we
think it's Studio Ghibli Museum but we
don't know I don't think so but we're
not that's not we're here we're here for
them another thing that way foreign I
hope I'm learning right oh I don't know
what it it's good hopefully we can can
check out a lot of things here because
it's like 20 minutes to get here but
it's nice it's worth them and we'll see
if we make it there I'll put the boat
the park was closed but we ended up in a
boating st. so I think that's is it a
cook
- I say faster much it doe as soon as I
said what comes out when I come down
what are you doing here what are you
doing here
we don't appreciate your guy hi hi dogs
I will kill you on they just come to say
hi ever so forgive me I know why but
don't tell anyone it's so pretty here
really
so we found a temple on the way I don't
think I'm allowed to film inside so it's
still pretty cool it's a part when I see
actually not really I lie I felt that it
was filming anyway President Lincoln's
been here we started ticket only good
job good job
we don't know what to do that we go back
it probably wasn't what we thought it
was anyway but it was nice to walk in
the park and steps and all the zoos were
closed so we picked a good day to go
here I think my hair is the best in
these vlogs beautiful that's how I style
my hair
I'm good so in Shibuya I think I don't
know I didn't pay attention where we
left yeah I don't recognize what we
offer at all well they have books and
stuff there so we go in there
we're gonna go shopping and that's all I
know
oh yeah everyone is looking at me hey
so this is the famous Shibuya crossing
you've probably seen it in movies and
some Jesus there's so many people I
don't even know all right I just want to
show it we're going in Nick I said we're
going here and for shopping whole step
is awkward I don't know what to do so
we're going back to the hotel because
we're lazy
we've been out for like five hours or
something and so we're taking a quick
break and stuff I don't even know how I
feel in this
okay great block great great thanks how
was your day
can't hear you wish I did good times
goodbye I'm so good at blocking we just
okay we're heading out again now and we
checked and it was actually the Studio
Ghibli Museum we were like it's probably
not here because it said whatever it
said you had to have reserved tickets
anyway sort of all right I can't believe
I forgot I bought new shoes I'm wiggling
my toes on the inside and these legs are
sexy mm-hm
what's one my hair today
it's like this every day so the first
time I have proper ramen before haha
really good where are we going
where we go nan where we going where are
we going
really breathily okay we're at the
Pokemon Center
we're going there right now I hear it's
pretty disappointing it's not much of a
center but we'll see I don't think I can
filming there I don't know but yeah I
don't think so we just got out of
Pokemon we bought a lot of stuff and now
we're going to the old part of Tokyo I'm
really tired but we're doing a lot of
stuff on the last day to make sure we do
everything so we found a really cool a
studio ghibli story I couldn't film it
but I buy a lot more stuff and there's a
temple it's really cool this area or
whatever it is that we're all by it's
pretty cool Pokemon I get looking at all
these cattle I'm not drunk
so cool some places often loving Jesus
so hypnotizing if you want a baby you
can get one in Japan
it says coop hi it's almost like me we
walk ties all the shops and we made it
to a temple I don't know what happens in
the temple but I bet it's gonna be
pretty awesome you're missing out and
raise your toe oh that's like a tower
there I don't see that that's awesome
everyone yep they're so polite like
they're moving as soon as you notice I'm
family anyway I should Bettis on them
thank you scary please awesome why
everyone's here it's very cool very cool
we bought so much stuff I'm so tired of
walking at 6:30 we've been out since
8:30 I've been awake since 4:00 a.m. and
we're leaving tomorrow it's a little
tight
oh thanks but yeah let's depend for you
we're finally back in Shibuya I'm so
tired
Jesus Christ there's a lot of people
insane how many people there are I don't
sorry we're back a nay the hotel I
wanted to show what I bought and I
bought
I didn't mean to buy these what hi
no one said hi to you that was key
thanks for interrupting I'm skiing so I
bought a bunch of satis I don't know why
no I don't all right so this is probably
my favorite one cuz it's like I have
what is it I my I had to pick it this is
a piggy bank and it really fits his
character because he gets like he's
holding the coin and you put it in the
back it's pretty cool okay it's pretty
cool next we have taupe Totoro and it's
a yeah okay well it's really cute
okay it's cute like they had some on top
it's cute I kissed his belly it's cute
and then finally I only bought this
because we were at the Pokemon store but
it's a ticket you on a golden Magikarp I
don't know why but it's it's pretty it's
pretty so those the thing I did I is
that really all I'm a lot more wait
what's up what's up ladies huh my name
is Thomas is the best best camera
alright I think that's all I buy I I
bought a bunch of clothes and stuff but
you don't need to see that your own we
have to pack now even though I'm
exhausted but yeah I'll do it but I'll
see you later alligator hate it it's
actually me don't be scared don't be
scared
alright brush we it's 5:00 in the
morning we're heading back home it's
raining outside so I guess we picked a
good way to go but I haven't been honest
with you Prez I can teleport and I do it
like this
we just got back and our our friend took
care of the dogs and haven't seen him in
days might they already yeah yeah Oh me
sorry we just got back
I'm really tired it's really light
actually not it's 5:00 so we have to
stay up I'm gonna record some videos bad
because I'm nothing better to do and I
have to stay awake so yay mmm and I hope
you enjoyed this vlog whatever we watch
I'm not good at vlogging I don't pretend
that I am I'm awful but I figured it'd
be fun to see a little bit of what we've
been doing and it's been a great week I
had a lot of fun and it's good good to
be back in a way too even though I am
yeah I don't know they like enjoy
watching South and Brits love you burn
her